okay let's take a look at the uh
chats okay so we have Marius
um
is interested in food microbiology and
infectious diseases all right so we have
two partisans who are interested in
infectious diseases and who are from
microbiology background
that's interesting uh Dohan is from
Indonesia and has a background in Agro
technology and has a bachelor's
research was using amplicon 16 as Gene
sequencing of soil sampling
oh that's pretty interesting and that's
how you got interested in metagenomics
uh let us go to the next person Prince
has studied genetics and biotechnology
and for Bachelors genetics for my
masters and now I'm doing my PhD and my
interest is in genomics I'm joining from
Benin City Nigeria thank you so much
friends for uh introducing yourself
what about the rest of you
I can see that some of you are still uh
uh a little bit shy to introduce
yourselves in the chat box but it would
be great if you could introduce yourself
you can feel free to let us know about
your educational background your
research interests just to get to know
uh the kind of participants with whom
we'll be interacting this for this
session
all right Muhammad is also is having a
microbiology background and a
specializing in virology
okay great so we have a lot of
microbiology students with interest in
infectious diseases
uh are you guys joining the uh session
for the very first time or have you been
enrolled in any of the programs before
is this your first time joining
do let us know in the chat uh that as
well
and I believe we have just few more
minutes left
all right uh Irene is Miami I hope I'm
pronouncing that correct as well is an
undergraduate biomedical science student
at the University of Cape Coast Kana and
is interested in the carrier of
neurogenomics that's pretty interesting
neurogenomics I've heard that term
before but not widely I've heard of it
but that's pretty interesting uh could
you please elaborate how you got
interested in that as well was it as a
part of your degree
did you come across research articles
and for those who are new to the term uh
feel free to like briefly explain that
as well I'm sure a lot of the
participants might be interested to know
uh we also have Dr Rhoda who's a
microbiologist and whose research
interest is in antimicrobial resistance
and bio control of infectious agent
and is interested in primer design
phylogenetry analysis and understanding
of Next Generation sequencing thank you
so much for joining today's session and
we hope that you'll find today's session
variable for your uh research work as
well
foreign
[Music]
has a background in infectious diseases
and biochemistry and Nelson is
interested in human genetics and is
currently working on sequencing human
exponent to identify snps and other
problems
that's pretty interesting to know as
well Nelson uh and what about the rest
of you I'm looking forward to your uh
updates as well for those of you who are
joined with us for the very first time
we are just catching up with the
participants knowing about what is their
educational background what are their
research entrails uh pretty much that
and feel free to let us know in the chat
as well for those of you who have just
joined and we'll be starting with this
session in just couple of minutes we are
waiting for a few more participants to
join in case they are
running a little bit late
all right so without further delay let's
start uh with today's session and for
those of you who have just joined us uh
again just you know feel free to
introduce yourself in the chat box a
couple of the participants have already
introduced themselves and along the way
of the session if you have any queries
please feel free to put them in the chat
as well and while we are presenting
we'll take a look at it and try to
address all of the queries that you have
all right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting welcome to omix project and
today we have the open interactive
session so the various fall thermostat
programs that we have on genomics and
metagenomics and during the session we
will introduce you to the Omens logical
guide you on how to navigate it walk you
through our meticulously designed
training curriculums for each program
the various training levels as well as
the associated resources
so before we begin with today's session
for those of you who are joining with us
for the very first time let me also take
a brief moment to introduce you to the
team behind the program we are a
us-based by informatics company who is
working with multiple academic and
Commercial moderators to develop easy to
use analytical tools and our mission is
to make bioinformatics for accessible
and so far the training program have
been completed by over 24 000
participants from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and our training
coordinators are regularly updating and
customizing the curriculum to suit the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
now in order to create a clear path of
skill development we employ the glooms
taxonomy levels of learning it begins
with students recalling and memorizing
facts progresses to understanding the
concepts and applying their knowledge
then moves on to analyzing data and
evaluating Memphis
ultimately students reach the highest
level of learning where they can design
and create their own original work
and now this is achieved uh through a
combination of online courses training
modules data analysis tools curated data
sets and interactive Mentor sessions to
provide theoretical and practical
learning in bi-informatics
now to further enrich the training
curriculum we also provide real case
studies that demonstrate the practical
application of bioinformatic methods and
omics data in fields such as medicine
biotechnology Agriculture and even
astrobiology
and by using publicly available data
sets these projects allow students to
explore and comprehend various research
questions and Analysis
and the omics logic loan portrait gives
students options for analyzing a given
data set which is code independent path
or code independent part
now if you are someone who is interested
in opting the non-code pathway they will
be given directions to access the T by
info platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data so this
platform includes example pipelines as
well as data management and Analysis
Cloud infrastructure to run various
bioinformatic Pipelines and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multi-omics
platform we will be covering about the
by and four platform in a short while
and now here are some of the student
Keys example that I want to share with
you briefly
so for the very uh one example that I
want to take is our student with she was
one of our students who worked on
assessing the underlying reason for gray
matter lesions in multiple sclerodic
patients and she went on to publish her
project in immunogenetics which is an
Open Access Journal that focuses on the
genetic research areas of autoimmune
disorders such as multiple sclerosis
rheumatoid arthritis and soup
and further you also have the
opportunity to participate in
post-presentation competitions and when
exciting cash prizes and twice a year we
conduct the Omens research Symposium
which is an international research event
that brings together experts from all
around the world
and the student projects are not just
limited to University students for
instance Andre muradino he was a high
school student when he joined one of our
training program and he presented his
Neuroscience project at the regenerone
international science and engineering
fair for which he won the potamkin prize
now this program can also be integrated
as a part of the existing University
curriculum for instance our python
course was part of the systems medicine
graduate program at Georgetown
University
and these projects can also be showcased
for various other purposes so here are
some of the instances of how our former
students have showcased their projects
so for example de la rat icon who got
accepted to eres Mendes imbrcd program
in Marine Biology then we had dhruv
mehra who is a Precision medicine
graduate student at Manchester and
anushati who got accepted to the PHD
program in metagenomic at University of
Sweden
now faculties and researchers have also
collaborated to our programs to publish
their research work and one of our
collaboration has been with a team of
researchers at mobuchi Memorial
Institute for medical research at the
University of Khanna to carry out
computational based study to understand
variants associated with sulfadoxin
resistance in plasmodium calcium
now let's say you are someone with a
passion for Science and business it is
also possible to pursue an
entrepreneurship and business Innovation
track like a team of industrial
researchers from a biotechnology company
in Nigeria
so they worked on developing a
microbiota test kit to improve the
fertility of women in Nigeria and
improve their chances of carrying their
babies to turn
now these entrepreneurship track are not
just pursued by researchers but by
students as well for instance a group of
undergraduate and postgraduate students
worked on developing an early detection
kit for Alzheimer's disease
so now you can take a look at all of
these student projects and researchers
project at our omex scholarship plan
portal so to view to view these let us
head to the open storage diploma portal
and for those of you who are joining
with us for the very first time let me
share the link in the chat box
so that um
you can create an account those
participants who are interested to take
a look at what are the various courses
what are the various training programs
we have and what are the various student
projects that have been completed so far
you can take a look at all of these
collections from our website
so um let me just give you a brief demo
on how you can sign up so for those of
you who are starting for the very first
time when you head to the link you will
see a create an account option like so
click on that and there it will ask you
to enter your name email ID password and
click on next and it will ask you to
enter a few more details once that is
done you will be able to log into your
account or if you already have a
existing social media account
Etc Google or Facebook or Apple account
or GitHub or Twitter you can also log in
just by clicking on that
now if you are someone who already has
an account on the Pro Photo then all you
can do is enter your existing email ID
and password and directly sign in so
I'll just pause for a couple of seconds
for those participants who are creating
an account and want to log in they can
do that
and along the way if you are facing any
technical issues while signing up please
feel free to put that in the chat as
well and our technical team will be able
to look into that so I'll just pause for
a couple of seconds and monitor for your
response
for those of you who already have an
account on the please put it done in the
chat box so that I get an idea and for
those who for those of you who are
creating an account and once done put a
yes in the chat box so that I love that
as well
[Music]
all right so I can see that a lot of the
participants have created an account
perfect
Arena says done josra says done Maria
says done
[Music]
Landry says done
all right maybe you who just joined we
are just signing up on the ominous
portal where I can take the participants
and showcase the various poses and
training programs that we have let me
quickly share the link in the chat box
so that uh
you can start with it
right so without further delay I'm just
going to sign in with my existing
account
all right so once you sign in the very
first interface that you are seeing is
the courses page where you will be able
to see a list of collection of courses
that we have on the boardroom so if you
scroll down below you will see a search
bar that says looking for a specific
course and here if you enter a key area
of research interest or let's say a
specific almost field that you want to
specialize in then you can enter the
keyword and it will show you the various
courses and example projects that you
that makes use of it so just as an
example I'm just going to enter the
keyword genomics which is associated
with
big session so as you can see it shows
up the relevant course which is on
genomics as well as a wide variety of
example projects ranging from infectious
diseases to uh oncology and so on so you
can explore this at your own pace and
take a look at the various courses and
example projects that we have on the
portal and now once you sign in you also
have to make sure that your profile is
updated so how do you do that you can
head over to the blue bar on the top
that is welcome back with your email ID
click on that and that will directly
take you to your account settings
and here if you click on the profile
button you will be able to
um edit all the account details that you
want to get updated on your profile
which includes your profile image make
sure that your name is in proper
spelling and proper capitalization and
you could also link your social media
handles as well as you can see in my
case I've linked my LinkedIn account and
my work ID and add a brief bio about
yourself as well so that we know who you
are what is your background what are
your research interests and my keys I've
linked I've mentioned my educational
background
the once that is done click on update
and that will be getting updated so that
was all about uh that I just wanted to
uh discuss with you so now to uh get
started with the uh fall semester
programs session I will pass on the
stage to my colleague somalikali over
teams
thank you so much can you confirm if you
can see my screen and if I'm Audible
well great a very warm good morning or
good evening in whichever part of the
world you are I'm sonalika Ray and I am
the Bayern Spanish project manager at
buying biotech today I'll talk about the
various four programs that we are
offering I will talk about each one of
the programs very briefly what it
includes and how the programs be
conducted so let's go by each one of
these programs one by one so for the
fall semester we have introduction to
bioinformatics genomic and metagenomic
data analysis and also biomedical data
analysis using python
so the goal of the Onix logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
which will enable independent research
Guided by mentors and pure example and
also develop a growing Community with
shared passion for data driven research
and appreciation of Citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of all the backgrounds to develop novel
and independent research using latest
technology in life and data Sciences
the training program would offer
personalized mental guidance expert
videos life support Hands-On tools and
certification as well on successful
completion of the program now let's take
you through the very first program that
is Introduction to bioinformatics
so for those who come from a
non-bioinformatics field let us quickly
understand what is bioinformatics and
how do we really use it
so bioinformatics is the science of both
storing lots of complex biological data
and of also analyzing it to find new
insights which we have to use in many
different ways for analysis and today's
biomedical research isn't simply about
publishing one set of results and hoping
other researchers read it it's about
finding patterns in all forms of data
linking everything that is out there to
provide new insights that we can only
spot if we can see the big picture
bioinformatics lets us bring together
the data from lots of experience in one
place so we can ask those big questions
and find the answers and such data from
different sources is available rather
than availability of such Rich sources
of data changes the nature of the
biological research itself as it is
rapidly acquiring the character of a
data science
now who uses bioinformatics and who is
it for the answer might have been
statisticians computer scientists or
Engineers but the truth is that more and
more biologists as well as clinicians
are now expected to understand and
handle their own data to publish and
succeed in basic and translational
research in fact biology itself is
rapidly acquiring the character of a
data science
so as biology is rapidly acquiring the
character of data science that I just
mentioned billions of data points on
genes proteins and other molecules are
compiled in large files and
systematically studied and analyzing
this data leads to more knowledge and
understanding about living organisms
which includes human health
biotechnology crops and livestock so
this training program will give an
overview of bioinformatics for
understanding multi-ohomics data
analysis for students biologists and
clinicians and the influx of data that
is associated with these methodologies
and data-driven research makes
bioinformatics for Life Sciences as
prominent as the emergence of computers
is for the tech industry
now the feed is based on high throughput
technologies that generates billions of
data points on genes proteins and other
molecules which characterize biological
systems and phenomena and these data or
this data that is compiled into the
repositories and can be systematically
studied to understand interrogate and
establish trends for many applications
which includes phenomics genomics
epigenetics and also transcriptomics and
what is missing here is single cell
transcript products
now the question is is such data
available yes and one such repository is
maintained by national Center for
biotechnology information which has a
collection of peer-reviewed Articles
biological data sets and projects on
various topics and as you can see in the
past several decades this resource has
been growing exponentially there are
over 80 000 publicly available data sets
in just one part of ncbi that is called
Geo which stands for gene expression
Omniverse and this is just one simple
example of a data repository which
contains data sets on thousands of genes
in each sample but in the program we'll
Explore More and More of such
repositories and understand what type of
data is stored in these repositories how
we can extract it and make the most out
of it
now the program is designed to highlight
the role of big omics data that is
shaping modern biomedical Innovation
where molecular data is used for
precision Diagnostics Big Data
integration and machine learning that is
transforming personalization of
treatment selection and Innovative
algorithms that allows for unprecedented
capabilities with drug Discovery design
of large molecules and even drug
repurposing
the program will cover some of the
important Technologies and its
applications in today's world the
participants will be able to access the
bioinformatics resources along with
expert and Mentor support to get help
with the learning process that will help
you learn the transformation of biology
to data-driven biology
and this was about the first program
introduction to Big Data bioinformatics
where we'll cover these aspects of
different omics analysis will get you
introduced to these different omics
analysis which includes a genomic data
analysis transcriptomic data analysis
metagenomics single cell
now let's discuss about the other
program which is genomic data analysis
so whether you are just starting your
journey or looking to expand your
expertise this program is designed to
provide you with the skills and the
knowledge that is needed to excel in
this rapidly evolving field of genomics
so there are three different levels of
the program that I'll take you through
when I go through the program pages of
these programs but to talk about the
topics I'll divide them up into beginner
intermediate and advanced level so at
the beginner level you will develop a
strong Foundation exploring
bioinformatics and also understanding
Next Generation sequencing data
exploration and also you will learn
about sequence alignment and more so
when we talk about sequence alignment
from there I get this picture of the
workflow that is very important for us
to understand so we have the sequencing
reads we need to understand uh how to
take it up for quality control and then
uh we align them up and after align
aligning them on the reference genome we
want to understand how we look for these
specific variants and then finally
understand what these variants actually
are or what type of variance these
actually are so we need to annotate them
what are the different types of files
that are included at all of these
different steps and what all of these
different steps includes and how do you
get to know about a specific type of
variant annotated effectively is what
the program is all about so at the
intermediate level it will we will take
you deep into the Intriguing topics such
as vegan calling we'll process the vegan
coin pipeline we look at the results
we'll try to interpret these biological
insights out of the results that we get
and we'll also discuss about
can you take care of this someone is
requesting to record the meeting locally
uh we can share the recording of the
session with you uh distance sorry if I
am pronouncing your name uh not
correctly we are also live on YouTube so
you have a link from there I'll deny a
request at the moment thank you
all right so from the variant calling
we'll also learn about copy number
variation analysis machine learning
genome-wide Association studies and also
briefly touch upon the ethical
considerations and for those seeking
Advanced knowledge we'll delve into
population genetics DNS sequence
analysis VCF file analysis functional
annotation and also we'll discuss about
these real life case studies on sarskov
to breast cancer oncogene radiant
calling and also Ebola
and by joining this program you will
gain practical hands-on experience learn
cutting a Cutting Edge techniques and
also unravel the Mysteries that are
hidden within the genomic data so be
prepared to unlock a world of exciting
possibilities and make significant
contribution in the field of genomic
data analysis
next up is metagenomic data analysis
to unravel the microbial community
to explore the Limitless potential of
metagenomic data analysis through our
comprehensive training program that is
designed for big notes intermediates and
also advanced level practitioners so
whether you are starting your journey or
seeking to expand your expertise this
program equips you with the skills and
the knowledge to excel in this Dynamic
field
now let's get back to understand where
did the metagenomics field come up from
so in the 1800s the link between disease
and the microorganisms was established
sharing light on isolated bacteria
functions and today we understand that
the human microbiome consists of
structured communities forming biofilms
with complex interactions aiding
ecological stability and advances in
metagenomics enables the study of the
vast majority of uncultivable
microorganisms within their natural
environments
so the course covers bioinformatics
analysis of metagenomic sequencing data
which includes genomic sequencing
Technologies data data utilization
analysis tool as well as real world
applications
so since the 1900s microbiome Studies
have made significant progress and
notably through initiatives like the
human microbiome project that enabled uh
that enables metagenomic sequencing
advances allows categorization of
microbiota in various human organs
presenting opportunities as well as
challenges in identifying their roles in
organ health and disease as well
so in the program we will learn about
these different types of metagenom
sequencing techniques to different types
of data that is generated we'll majorly
focus on 16s metagenomic sequencing and
the Gen and the data generated from it
such as otu sequences that is annotated
by mapping onto a reference database
such as the ribosomal database project
RDP green genes or the silver database
and such databases contain taxonomic
information for the domains of bacteria
Archaea and Eukarya as well that is
based primarily on phylogenese for small
subunit rrnas which includes 16s
prokaryotes and 18s for you get out
now based on the mapping of specific
regions Amplified from the 16s RNA Gene
in this small subunit of the bacterial
ribosome
otus can be assigned to belong to a
taxonomic class of bacteria eating a
proportionate view of the community and
each Community can then be studied by
comparing with others or between similar
communities in different conditions or
individuals and such analysis includes
an in-depth understanding of data
preparation reference databases and
analytical approaches to answer specific
questions based on solid evidence upon
importantly sequencing data that
represents only one type of microbial
omics with many more becoming
increasingly available
so there are many questions about the
role of microbiome members and the
communities that are now being answered
using Next Generation sequencing genomic
data as well as mass pick approaches for
proteomics and metabolomics indeed the
next phase of microbiome research lies
in the ability to integrate
multi-ohomish data sets that combine NGS
Mass Spec and structural data with
phenotypic information about the overall
changes in the community and their
environment
and in the program we will go through
these three different pipelines that are
just briefly touch upon the first one is
the taxonomy classification when we have
the data to pipeline that denoises and
corrects errors in amplicon sequence
data providing high resolution
error-free sequence variance as output
and next we will also learn about kind
to pipeline which analyzes and processes
microbial Community data offering
diverse outputs like taxonomic
assignments diversity Matrix and
visualizations
and behind many of these methods are
scripts that are written in popular
coding languages such as R and Python
and these are also explained in the
tutorials that you will have an access
to as a part of the program that I just
take you through briefly
it includes beginner tutorials on data
importing preparation for analysis and
also standard visualization of the
process data and more specialized
package packages with publication ready
outputs that will also be covered in
more advanced lessons in the
metagenomics coursework and the case
studies that we'll take you through
we will also learn about the basics of
functional metagenomics that explores
the genetic potential and metabolic
activities of microbial communities in a
given environment
so what kind of projects can be studied
using metagenomic sequencing or
metagenomic data
in the program we'll go through these
number of application applications that
include skin conditions food sensitivity
of the gut autoimmune disk orders cancer
antibiotic resistance and also we'll try
to understand the microbiome that is
involved in drug resistance and even in
ecological studies these are just few
applications that we'll touch upon that
I just mentioned but there are more such
case studies that we'll cover in the
program
in this program we'll also learn to find
and analyze data from such repositories
as the human microbiome project which
includes a data set that is called the
American gut this the citizen science
project has a lot to offer for those
interested in basic microbial
composition of different types of
samples from healthy and mildly sick
individuals
so that was about metagenomic data
analysis and the next program that is
being offered this fall is biomedical
data science using python
so the demand for scale data analysts
and scientists who can derive meaningful
insights from biomedical data has never
been greater and that's where our online
winter guided training program on
biomedical data science using python
comes into play
in today's rapidly evolving world of
biomedical research the generation of
big data has become the norm every day
vast amounts of valuable biomedical data
is being produced holding the potential
to revolutionize our understanding of
diseases and paved the way for
groundbreaking medical discoveries
however the sheer volume and also the
complexity of this data presence a
significant Challenge and that's where
data analysis comes in so this
comprehensive program is designed to
equip you with the knowledge and the
skills that you need to excel in the
field of biomedical data science and
through a combination of practical
assignments live workshops and online
resources you will embark on a
transformative Learning Journey that
will Empower you to unlock the potential
of high throughput biomedical data
so now what the different types of
levels will include the bigger Level
Training Program serves as a very solid
foundation in Python Programming and its
applications to biomedical data analysis
we understand that not all of you come
from a bioinformatics background that's
why we'll also introduce you to the
different types of biomedical data omics
data that is being generated and what is
what the structure of this data looks
like and then we'll get started with the
very basics of the fundamentals of
python in the beginning
we'll start by understanding the basics
such as data variables control
structures and also we'll discuss about
functions and modules
then we'll dive into data processing and
cleaning using powerful libraries like
numpy and pandas armed with these skills
you will move on to the expiratory data
analysis leveraging visualization
libraries like matplotlab and c-bond to
uncover patterns and relationships that
are hidden within your data Additionally
you will gain an understanding of
dimensionality reduction techniques and
machine learning using cycle cloud
and as you progress to the intermediate
level you will deepen your understanding
of clustering and advanced machine
learning techniques specifically
tailored for biomedical data analysis
you'll explore clustering techniques
like k-means hierarchical clustering
spectral clustering using python
clustering packages like scikit and
sci-fi and you'll also learn about model
validation techniques and evaluation
Matrix for supervised machine learning
models furthermore you will delve into
the advanced machine learning techniques
like decision trees random forests svm
LDA
Uma and apply them to the real world
biomedical problems and last but not the
least
I want to discuss about the artificial
intelligence where in today's data
driven World AI that is powered by
Technologies like chat GPT that is all
around the place has revolutionized the
way we approach scientific research and
data analysis and as Learners you have a
remarkable opportunity to harness the
power of AI to unlock new insights
streamline complex tasks and also
accelerate your Learning Journey AI
particularly the code interpreter that I
am very fond of can provide assistance
by generating code for complex analysis
and also Auto main routine tasks for
those who are biologists and are not
hardcore programmers this is a blessing
in disguise additionally it can produce
insightful visualizations such as heat
maps dendrograms and also other plots to
help you visualize and enter your data
very effectively we are com we are
committed to equipping you with the
knowledge and the skills to leverage
these AI capabilities as well in your
academic and research and divorce which
can fasten up the pace of your research
and also definitely have these complex
tasks done in a less time
together sorry together we'll embark on
a transformative learning experience to
explore these Endless Possibilities that
AI offers in the realm of biology and
Beyond so that was all about these
different training programs that I
wanted to discuss and now I'll quickly
share my screen and take you through
the omics logic learn portal the
resources that we would be covering or
the resources that you would get an
access to as a part of this program
already took you through the amishogic
learn portal and helped you understand
where your profile is where the courses
are I'll just take you through the
specific resources that you have an
access to as a part of the program and
what all you need to cover
so for those who are interested in
introduction to Big Data bioinformatics
program
they can visit the program page I'll
just show how to uh visit the program
page or how to reach the program page so
on the portal you have a courses Tab and
then you have a programs tab under the
programs tab you have all the programs
uh that are currently running
so you need to hear
look for you can also type
bioinformatics you simply need to click
on the specific program page of your
interest and because I already have it
open I won't reopen it again but but
I'll just show you how it's done once
you have the access to a specific
program the program page will also
appear on your profile as a button so
that it's easy for you to access it so
if this is your profile on the extreme
left you have the badges here and if you
click on it you will be redirected to
the program page
a lot of program
users and our students have doubts on
how to get the access to the program
page so that was just a brief demo on it
all right now coming back to the program
page let's now discuss about the
sections of the program page so that
it's easy for you to uh just go through
all of these resources on this program
page you'll have all the lectures and
the resources put together
so we have three levels as I mentioned
beginner intermediate Advanced there are
different number of sessions for each
level it depends uh how much time you
have and also uh what type of expertise
you need for the under the specific type
of program so for the beginner level we
have six sessions intermediate we have
another six sessions and advanced we
have 12 sessions
so in the beginner level we'll introduce
you to the very basics of molecular
biology and bioinformatics again the
idea here is to introduce you to the
field by informatics for those coming
from a non-bioinformatics field you
might be a biochemist or a
microbiologist and we have also noticed
in Trust of medical students in the
field of bioinformatics so this specific
session will help you get started
now if you look at the resources for a
specific session let's look at the
breakdown you have the session
objectives you have the session outcomes
and then fourth specific session you
have some paths under it there could be
two parts three or four parts under each
session and for each part you have a
session video that is a session lecture
that you need to watch and you also have
the associated lesson that you need to
complete and you also have a keywords
head book that you can go through and
the additional reading material
because this is just the very beginning
of a session that's why you don't have
uh the Practical Hands-On but if you
scroll down and explore other sessions
you can see we have more parts here and
also you will get a link to the demo
Pipeline and the Practical Hands-On for
practical Hands-On you have the data
so if an obsession uh the mentor is
taking you through a practical let's say
so the data set that the mentor used
you'll have the link to that data here
and you also have a link to the demo
pipeline that I'll just take you through
and you also have to go through the
lesson that you have mentioned here and
some additional reading material
now apart from watching the lecture you
have to complete the associated lesson
now where is the lesson actually based
so under the courses tab you have these
various courses and you also have these
example projects so I can call them case
studies after completing a coursework
it's very important it's very important
for you to understand how a specific
research question could be answered with
the skill set that you gained through a
coursework so for that you need to go
through these case studies as well that
has been structured well in the program
that will help you give a wholesome
experience that is from learning about
these specific Concepts to also having a
practical hands-on experience with these
case studies
so as I was talking about introduction
to bioinformatics along with the program
you have to go through the
bioinformatics coursework too that is
the first course on the portal that is
Introduction to bioinformatics now the
courses on the portal are structured are
placed in such a manner that under each
course you have several lessons that you
need to complete as a part of the
training program
and on the training program page for
each of these sessions you have one or
two of these lessons covered that you
need to complete so you have a
structured way in that you have to
follow to watch the lecture you complete
some of these lessons
just a second
all right I needed a quick water break
so you can see that you have these
lessons under each coursework
and for the score of for that specific
session you need to complete a list
so that is how uh these lessons on the
program page are given
now let's look into the lesson
so what is present inside the lesson
inside the lesson you will find the
concept that is given you'll also find
some lectures or Mentor videos very
short-minded videos that you have to go
through and also you will find
the assignments and also quizzes that
you need to complete in order to
complete a specific lesson
so that is how a lesson is structured
in the introduction to bioinformatics
coursework as I mentioned that in the
training program our goal is to
introduce you to the field
bioinformatics and also to talk about
different types of omics data be it
genomic data transcriptomic data
metagenomic or single cell or epigenomic
data so that you have an understanding
of what the field bioinformatics is all
about
and if I now proceed ahead with the next
program that is genomic data analysis
just a second
yes
all right so if you proceed ahead with
the next program that is genomic data
analysis you will have the sessions
given in the same order a beginner
intermediate and an advanced level and
for the genomics training program you
have to take up the course that is
genomics
that is code 3 genomics right you need
not navigate the course uh like I did
under the courses tab you have the links
of each and every lesson of the course
on the program page itself I'm just
showing you the main source of it so
that you know where the specific
coursework or the lesson is placed
now in the genomics course we are taking
you from the very basics of genomics
then you're discussing about the Next
Generation sequencing techniques types
what type of genomic data do we get
different types of genomic data all
right be it uh targeted data or be it
the whole genome or whole exam data and
after discussing about the types of data
we discuss about sequence alignment
phylogenetic analysis variant calling
mutability analysis differential
mutation analysis and then in the
coursework itself you can see that some
of these lessons have the learn batch
while some of these lessons have the r
code patch
so also while discussing the concepts
and exploring the Practical Hands-On
will also take you through the r code
blocks to understand and learn how R can
be used as a computational language to
work with genomic data and perform
different types of analysis now as I
mentioned about these different types of
analysis that we would carry out uh for
the Practical experience where do we
actually do it so for those who are new
and have joined the session for the
first time for them uh you have two
resources one is the omics logic learn
portal to learn about these different
types of Concepts and then you have the
T bioinfo platform that you use for your
practical Hands-On so this is the
educational Reservoir and then you have
here the Practical Hands-On T bioinfo
platform
on the platform you have different areas
of analysis transcriptomics genomics
single cell transcriptomics metagenomics
then you have machine learning here as
well here you have givas and phyogenic
Analysis too now because I'm discussing
about the genomic data analysis program
so I'll just highlight the major
analysis that we are going to cover
under this program and for this program
we will be covering variant calling that
is given here project analysis and jivas
as well
now if you can see there is a drop down
button in front of each and every main
pipeline that is actually a demo
pipeline or an educational pipeline that
is based on a case study on the omics
logics non-portal so I'll just quickly
process this demo pipeline to show you
how you can use the demo pipelines for
uh learning about these different tools
or algorithms that could be used for
analysis and then we look at the results
the outputs that we get from the
pipeline and we try to understand how do
we interpret the biological insights out
of the results that we obtain by
processing a pipeline here the data has
already been uploaded at the back end
and I'm just processing the pipeline to
show you how easy it is to process a
genomic data analysis pipeline for
variant calling and you can also do that
and what results we get and how do we
interpret this is just a demo and I just
wanted to introduce you to these
different resources so I'll not get in
too much depth of it right now and
explain you how to interpret it we'll
take it up in the sessions obviously
meanwhile this loads let me open the
chat box and I can see there are some
comments here
comments about certification and
recording uh please address them you can
share the link with them and also SRI
gauri will share the recording uh with
all of you on your email once it's
processed so don't worry about it for
all the technical issues you can reach
out to Mrs
bio if you are trying to sign up and if
you face any issues he would be there to
assist you
and uh
okay we have a question by ratnadi is it
possible to analyze the data of dementia
patients using data to pipeline or can
we use dendrograms
data or genomic data you can definitely
perform character clustering on it and
have 10 programs and try to understand
how the dementia patients
um separate out from the controls right
but when when you're talking about data
too it completely depends if you have
the gut microbio or a specific my
obviously if it's dementia patients it
has to be uh the my the microbiome from
so there's a gut brain access component
or um
concept that you might have heard about
if not uh we can discuss about that as
well so if you have the microbiome data
for the for the dementia patients then
it would actually be very interesting to
understand the microbial composition or
the dysbiosis in dementia patients
because it's well known
um and also we have worked on such
neurosciences based projects on
Alzheimer's or Parkinson's where we have
tried to look at the microbial
compositions and try to understand which
genes they affect or which Pathways they
are affecting eventually based on the
substrate the communities are producing
so yes we can process a data to pipeline
as well to understand the data of
dementia patients but it obviously has
to be a 16 as data maybe that would be
the best if you have to process a data
to pipeline or R platform because on our
platform for data to analysis you need
to have a 16s data
and there are various repositories that
you can explore to get the data for
dementia patients that we can discuss in
the program
how do we get co-certification Muhammad
movies
will let you know about it once the
program is completed you get the
certificate I'll also show you uh
towards the end
what is the best pipeline to analyze
Mbox data land read again depends what
type of analysis you want to do we can't
uh pick a pipeline just while thinking
what the best pipeline could be to
analyze this type of data uh to pick a
pipeline it depends what type of
research question do you have in uh your
hand
and okay
yes we have the recording we share the
recording with you
and for certificates SRI gauri has
addressed it
and also ratnadi if your question was
answered uh or if you have any other
question you can please put it in the
chat box or you can also unmute yourself
and ask
good evening actually my question is as
you mentioned about the data to
pipelines okay to analyze having if we
have the specific 16s sequenced
microbiome data sets so my question is
basically as we are focusing on the gut
brain axis in the gut brain axis if at
the time of dementia if it is affecting
the thalamus action or the hypothalamus
so if uh is it mandatory that we have to
be having that again at the same time to
check out how much it is degenerated or
how much it is affected can be
calculated using these data to piaglines
or dendrograms or can we use heat Maps
we can use all three of them if we have
the access to the 16s microbiome data uh
we can process a data do pipeline to
understand uh the com the composition
and the affected genes and the pathways
as well and uh if we have the rnse data
uh we can definitely proceed ahead with
the machine learning approach and try to
understand through dendrograms or heat
Maps where genes are affected and then
try to understand the pathways that are
getting affected
to uh identify those Pathways which is
being affected do we need like markers
like red fluorescence protein RFP or gfp
to so that we can analyze using any
machine learning or dendograms
so will that is
like does that biomarker will affect it
like while we are analyzing using this
data to pipelines or uh heat maps and
dendrograms does that biomarkable has
any effect on these data set
analysis you have to first of all look
at the biomarkers and from the
biomarkers only you get to know about
the specific Pathways that would be
affected secondly you are trying to make
these two concepts data two is an
entirely different type of analysis that
would be done on microbial data the type
of data here is different all right and
if you want to if you want to uh bring
in the concept of bioparkers while
understanding how the microbial
composition affects specific genes or
your biomarkers and then you try to
understand the pathways that is
functional metagenomics and if you want
to understand with the rnse data how uh
or what specific type of genes or
biomarkers you say affect a specific
pathway that is with RNA Secret
all right so okay these three different
types of data analysis is possible but
again it depends what type of data do
you have
from your lab or you want to do a
project Based on data that is publicly
available
okay Mom thank you
and also if you have a specific research
proposal and you want to discuss further
yeah
and what should be the methodology that
has to be used and what type of results
you will get because this is just a very
broad discussion if you want to get more
into uh itself and try to understand
which specific plots you will get in
what specific patterns do you want to
look for for that we can have a
one-on-one call where we can discuss
your project objectives and guide you uh
accordingly oh come I'm surely like if I
can get the like email or the contact
infos and also that you can have one in
one discussion for it
for any uh discussions based on projects
you can reach out to me on Channel Bio
and also for any questions you can also
reach out to Communications logic.com
okay Mom thank you so much okay thank
you
thank you
and um this is what the genomic data
analysis uh pipeline Resort looks like
this is a g browse 2 version that is
linked with the genomic data analysis
Pipeline and here you have all of these
samples and you just select the
reference sequence and zoom in a little
bit and I can here look for the gene of
Mind trust this is a breast cancer uh
breast cancer pipeline where we have
these patients who are affected with the
specific type of breast cancer and we
have some control patients normally
patients not affected by breast cancer
and I'm interested to look at the
variance here so this is the reference
genome I can see I can just zoom in
um more and look at the sequence I have
the the option here to just look at the
nucleotides or amino acids and if I zoom
out a little bit I can look at the CNB
and the interpretation is quite lengthy
but we will take it out in the sessions
so that was a very brief overview of the
variant calling Pipeline and similarly
we have a pipeline on phylogenic
analysis that we'll take it up where
we'll try to understand how we can take
these sequences perform multiple
sequence alignment and then
um Carry Your phylogenic analysis how do
we get these different types of trees
how do we interpret the results from
that
because time is a constraint for this
webinar I'll not go in much depth right
now but uh we'll take up all of these
different points of analysis through the
t-bio info platform and also we will
learn how we could use the oh
open source tools and softwares to carry
out all these different types of
analysis and definitely learn uh how
code could be used to take up all of
these different types of analysis
so that was about the genomics program
I'll just uh close these two tabs so
that we're not confused and now let's
discuss about the metagenomic data
analysis program
so for the metagenomic data analysis
program we again have these three
different levels beginner intermediate
and advanced and for this we have to go
through the metagenomics training
program one thing that I uh skipped to
mention before uh when you were
discussing about these two different
programs if you type a spec a specific
keyword in the search bar like genomics
or meta genomics or bioinformanty
bioinform and click on Project
you'll get the list of all the case
studies or the projects for that
specific topic so if it's meta genomics
we have these four case studies here
that we'll explore and go through so you
will have these four case studies here
okay now in the metagenomics coursework
again we have the concepts covered and
also we have the r uh code block lessons
that we will go through so as I
mentioned in metagenomics we have these
three major pipelines that we will go
through the first one is for taxonomy
classification and then you have the
data to Pipeline and the kind to
pipeline as well to understand Alpha
diversity beta diversity and other poor
Matrix and functions as well through
Kyle analysis you all can create an
account on the omics logic learn portal
and after 24 hours of it you will get
the access to the T bioinfo platform if
that does not happen you should reach
out to us on communication
logic.com and we'll give you your demo
credentials uh if you want to explore
and see how these different types of
pipelines work and as a part of the
training program you will get the access
to the debug info platform where you
will learn how these pipelines are
processed what tools are used what
parameters to select and what results
you get and how do you interpret them
and before you process a pipeline it's
very important to understand which
public repositories have these specific
types of data that you can extract and
how do you clean up your files and how
do you process your data to be ready to
process these pipelines and when the
data is ready to upload and process
these Pipelines
so that was about metagenomics data
analysis program and now it comes to
biomedical data science using python so
for this program we have these three
levels again the beginner intermediate
and the advanced level and on this uh
specific program page of biomedical data
science using python you'll also find
the link to the Google collabs
now we will learn or learn the code of
these different types of analysis using
python through two different ways
the first one is definitely the
coursework so you have these two courses
on the portal one is python course one
and another one is python course 2. so
for those who opt for the beginner level
or or the basic level can just take a
course one but for those who opt for an
intermediate or an advanced level we can
take up course too now the course two
will take you from a very beginner level
to one advanced level where you will
understand from the very basic that is
how to install python or how to install
different libraries and packages for
python on your system how to install
anaconda and the required files to
process the jupyter notebooks
and also then you will learn about how
to import data how to import different
types of data how to normalize data how
to perform dimensionality reduction
apply statistical techniques and also
you will learn about different machine
learning techniques which includes
unsupervised analysis supervised
analysis and also you will learn about
deep learning and network analysis now
inside the lesson I'll just show you one
of these lessons inside the lesson
you'll learn about the concept of a
specific topic so if it is Data
normalization or law or log
transformation why is it important why
is it required and then you'll also
learn about the code block and you have
the explanation of the code block given
as well the libraries or the packages
that are used what do they do why are
they used what type of analysis thing
you expect from them what type of
results do you get from a specific code
block and for your practice towards the
end of the lesson you have a practice
code step where you have a link of a
Google collab that you need to open and
practice the code block that is given in
the lesson so when you practice through
Google collapse make sure that you copy
that collab and then you can practice
your code block along with that you also
have a session by scholar that you can
practice the code script we refer
collapse because if you are working with
the code block and you get stuck in
between you can reach out to us with the
link to your Google collab and we'll
help you rectify the errors that you
might uh get in your code so that is the
reason why we work with Google collabs
and also you have the links here that
you can refer to so that is how we plan
to uh teach you
python for different analysis are these
different steps
now comes a point uh where you have to
understand how to register for the
program
if there are any questions you can
please put in the chat box
we can discuss about it uh we can
discuss about the research objective and
then we can discuss the terms of the
platform accessibility for processing
your pipelines all right
okay I'll just simply log out first
so that I get the interface
all right so now once you're on the
omissogic learn portal and have signed
up and you want to enroll yourself for a
specific program you can simply open up
the program page and if you scroll down
foreign you can see three different
levels mentioned here beginner
intermediate and advanced and in
whichever level you are interested to
pick you can simply click on the buy now
button you can reach out to miss SRI
gaurian on
communication.com we have these codes
that you can use for getting a
scholarship to enroll yourself for the
program and SRI gauri will assist you on
getting the access to the code and then
proceeding ahead with it so you can pick
the level of your interest and we have
mentioned here what all access you will
get as a part of the level and it
depends first of all based on the length
so beginner level you get the access of
the program for a month intermediate is
for two months an advanced level is for
three months and also when you complete
the advanced level you get an
opportunity to work on a Capstone
project and if you have a research
question in your head already that you
want to work on like that has a research
question that he uh mentioned so if you
have a research question that you want
to work on we can discuss that and we
can uh work on a mini project sort of
thing that you can use to submit in your
college or so so an advanced level will
give you the access to work on a
Capstone project and if you want to work
on a research project after completing
the training program you also have that
option because once you complete the
program you understand all the concepts
that are required to work on a project
but then you need just the directions on
how to work on the research project how
to pick up a research question what data
to take what pipelines to process what
customizations you need and then finally
the the results that you get how do you
effectively interpret them and take it
up for a publication so that is also an
option after completing the advanced
level training you can work on a
research project that we can discuss
so that was about different uh levels
and how do you register for those who
are in different parts of the world you
can scroll up and here is a button just
next to the log out or the login option
and you can just change your currency
for example I'm in India so if I change
it to INR I'll be then able to look at
the cost of the program in in
so that would be a shed to you that was
all that we wanted to discuss about the
program what access you will get through
the program and also how do you register
yourself for the program if there are
any questions you can put in the chat or
you are free to unmute yourself and we
can discuss